si on avait dit à un esclave noir
américain qu'il posséderait un jour en
raticide en sud de l'alberta
il n'y aurait sans doute beaucoup et
pourtant l'histoire de john ware est
bien réelle l'homme est devenu au
tournant du 20e siècle
l'un des cas boys les plus respectées
dans l'ouest
toutes ces terres près de calgary lui
ont appartenu et physique au stress et
aux faux goûts et historienne elle
prépare un documentaire sur john ware
dont avait déjà traité une série de la
bbc
[Musique]
remarquable personnes john ware c'est
vraiment une personne remarquable comme
mes ancêtres ils étaient esclaves aux
états unis mais on ne sait pas où
exactement ce qu'on sait c'est qu'à la
fin de la guerre de sécession en 1865
john ware est affranchi et travaille
alors comme cabaye au texas dans l'idaho
du montana avant de traverser la
frontière
iman avec d'autres hommes un troupeau de
3000 bêtes jusqu'en alberta et c'est
durant ce voyage qu'il se forge tout une
réputation usb 3 6 il était très habile
avec les chevaux on disait de lui il n'y
a aucun cheval qu'il ne peut pas monter
il savait toujours où trouver la
nourriture et de l'eau pour ses bêtes
les gens le respectent et personne ne
l'avait vu tomber de cheval des talents
qui l'ont aidé à se faire accepter par
les blancs selon cet autre historienne
id est une âme doigts qui a réussi dans
une société penchent plutôt que de
retourner aux états unis john wells se
marient fonde une famille établie son
propre wrench près des rocheuses vie
rêvée ou presse
car au canada aussi le racisme est
omniprésent le gouvernement du canada et
particulièrement les gouvernements des
provinces ou des territoires de l'ouest
ne voulait pas un nom très tôt trop
poussée des noirs ils ont obtenu même du
gouvernement canadien qu'il interdise
les migrations des noirs
à cause de cette loi fédérale ni en
vigueur en 1910 peu noir s'établissent
au canada au cours des décennies
suivantes
histoire de john ware qui venait souvent
près des grilles se termine tragiquement
ironie du sort le grand cavalier meurt
écrasé par son cheval en 1905
avec son documentaire géo fougau espère
que d'autres comme elle se passionneront
pour ce cas boy légendaire people steal
things avec abu aspinall présent quand
on pense à un cow boy
on pense toujours un blanc même s'il y
en a beaucoup qui étaient noirs
hispaniques autochtone c'est la même
chose pour moi ma famille est arrivée
dans l'ouest canadien en 1910 et encore
aujourd'hui on me demande d'où je viens
c'est très frustrant
il ya des personnes noires dites elles
ont contribué à la construction de
l'ouest et les figures comme john ware
mérite une place de choix dans notre
mémoire collective
ici le remportait radio-canada à millar
ville de calgary
[Musique]